ton après huit mois d'hibernation
deauville s'éveille il faut redonner son
éclat à l'immense plage plage à préparer
avec ce beau soleil de printemps c'est
sûr
les touristes vont arriver en nombre
jérôme leur prépare un tapis douillet
prestige que soient le mieux possible
pour être celle du soleil american c'est
joli à voir
c'est mieux que de travailler dans bien
des shows en plus formidable une partie
de la renommée de la ville est née de
ses couleurs
[Musique]
cinq exactement les parasols ornent les
lieux depuis plus de 50 ans et ici on
est fier d'annoncer qu'ils sont
fabriqués en normandie et non pas en
chine
[Musique]
c'est du coton tressé et on fait toutes
les coutures tous les points de couture
et on ajoute les petits anneaux au bout
à la main d'homme s'est transmis de
génération en génération satio des
pistes un savoir faire artisanal qui
coûtent une petite fortune entre 4 et
500 euros le parasol à balawi la qualité
ça dure dans le temps
à peine ouvert les parasols donne le
signal les premiers touristes
envahissent la plage face à deauville
tout le charme de dos nu avec un beau
soleil comme ça la saison 2015 est lancé
deauville fait rêver depuis plus de 150
ans la station balnéaire a été créée de
toutes pièces pour accueillir les beaux
jours venus les parisiens en week-end la
mode des bains de mer est lancé les
élégantes fortunés recherche aussi du
confort pour les accueillir dignement
l'un des premiers palaces français ouvre
ses portes en 1912 à deauville 290
chambres grand luxe en bord de mer à
seulement 200 km de la capitale
un hippodrome et rapidement construit le
cheval est l'un des loisirs de l'époque
[Musique]
le succès va grandissant les privilégiés
viennent en week end en voiture et se
font construire des villas d'exception
internationale à tel point que le
festival du film américain est créé et
accueille les plus grandes stars pierce
brosnan jessica chastain ou encore
harvey keitel
au fil des années le tourisme devient
une industrie l'été chaque jour
trente mille visiteurs profitent de la
plage une réussite qui attise la
convoitise sur la commune voisine un
cinq étoiles vient d'ouvrir
bien décidé à avoir lui aussi sa part du
gâteau les femmes parasols ne suffisent
plus à attirer les touristes
la vieille dame va devoir batailler pour
maintenir son aura légendaire voyage
dans une nouvelle saison à deauville
[Musique]
ce jour là le temps grisâtre et la pluie
n'entameront pas la bonne humeur du
maire de la ville philippe augier ça va
ils seront un événement d'importance à
l'aéroport et même si l'endroit
ressemble plus à un aérodrome les plus
grands s'y sont déjà posées quand on a
accueilli g8 d'ailleurs le président
obama a atterri ici tous les autres
aussi d'ailleurs un medvedev sarko tu
sais qu'ils ont tous à péri ici si
monsieur le maire se déplace en personne
c'est pour inaugurer le premier vol
régulier londres deauville
voilà voilà voilà voilà j'ai beau plus
avis et vous le voisin allumé haye et
franchement ça fait cinquante vrai
un rêve car maintenant trois fois par
semaine cet avion débarquera des
centaines de nouveaux touristes
et voilà l'appareil est accueilli avec
les honneurs
il nous fait un ballet la diligence je
veux serrer la louche des premiers et
leur dire que welcome to deauville où
elle comme tous normandie il sait que
les compagnies low cost amène une autre
clientèle of the passenger des slimes
mayer deauville
welcome welcome to deauville où elle
campe une amende est arrivé beaucoup
beaucoup de jeunes
c est formidable
c'est l'idéal pour le week-end quand on
dit à londres à moins de 60 euros
l'aller-retour pour londres
l'appareil affiche complet deauville
vient de frapper un grand coup au début
de la saison des week-ends prolongés
désormais les londoniens arrivée par
avion vont s'ajouter aux parisiens venus
plus classiquement par la route chaque
vendredi soir
il arrive de paris par milliers comme
cette petite famille contente d'être
enfin arrivés en week-end et pour
prendre du bon temps du bon temps grand
luxe
jérôme et solène auront à se soucier de
rien il ne passe pas le week-end
n'importe où mais au mythique hôtel
normandy en bons clients
ils sont accueillis par le directeur en
personne à la maison vous avez fait mal
route
ça s'est bien passé bienvenue à l'hôtel
normandy hôtels de luxe dit traitement
vip pour cette enseignante et ce cadre
dirigeant je prépare banque et investi
les enfants ont droit à des petits
cadeaux un cahier de coloriage et des
jumelles pour se tenait bien voici
[Musique]
jérôme et solesmes se sont offert l'un
des musts du palace un appartement
familial
la décoration est neuf mais toujours
dans l'esprit de l'époque
coco chanel habitué des lieux n'y aurait
vu que du feu
c'est bien 55 m² pour 650 euros la nuit
dernière attention pour les enfants
regardent c'est pour toi
bée ware pib impeccable seven talent
dépaysement garanti
à seulement deux heures de paris j'ai
regardé par la fenêtre y voit le jardin
c'est un endroit je trouve où on est
comme confiné on est on est bien quoi on
est vraiment coupé de couper du monde et
du stresseurs quotidien et là ça faisait
ça depuis la fin d'année où on n'est pas
venu
ça permet de faire un petit break avec
son style de manoirs anglo-normand à
colombages le normandie et le plus vieil
hôtel de deauville
depuis plus d'un siècle il garantit une
clientèle régulière et fortunés à la
ville
dans son sillage toutes les grandes
marques de mode s'y sont installés les
terrasses rappelle celle des quartiers
chics de paris l'été
[Musique]
au petit matin il y en a un qui redonne
au lieu un petit air de tradition et de
simplicité
les penderies jean paul arrive toujours
le premier sur le marché aux poissons
il possède l'un des plus gros
restaurants de la ville
therrien du calamar ouais c'est la
taille c'est même mieux celle là quand
c'est trop gros s'est pas tu peux pas
faire des beaux calamars frits et
l'espagne et ifremer de qualité
[Musique]
jean-paul achète 10 kg d'un corner un
des meilleurs
j'aime bien venir de bonheur parce que
les soit il a le choix et à 80 passant
derrière comme ça oui sinon je suis bien
veut pas il a péché bon on va prendre
les petites crevettes maintenant ça ces
deux derniers le pêcheur de crevettes
qui reste d'autres ça c'est pour à
l'apéritif pour les gens qui y viennent
manger mais une petite folie de
crevettes
free est comme ça ou cuites à l'eau oui
oui
[Musique]
oléron vivante de tous les matins comme
ça bon bonne journée
oui
malgré les apparences
jean-paul ne dirige pas un restaurant
gastronomique mais cette pizzeria
l'endroit ne paie pas de mine pourtant
depuis 37 ans ils n'accueillent que des
habitués et pas des moindres c'est libre
dehors amicalement alain de l'eau chaude
et sucrée du champ de gretz gêne chez
nous par le trampling smaïn depardieu
carole bouquet et marc sharif
tutto va bene serveurs ici pendant une
trentaine d'années
jean paul a vu passer toutes ces
célébrités en 2012
il a repris la sphère et perpétuent la
tradition c'était mon cerveau trop de
tele2 travaillait depuis longtemps basse
et voix
oui là c'était monsieur sarkozy et
madame cardin carla bruni ou des stars
hollywoodiennes aux animateurs télé
comme cyril hanouna tous les people ont
fait de sa pizzeria à leur qg
ce qu'ils aiment bien ici c'est ils sont
le coni tôt on les embête pas ils
mangent tranquillement en famille et
autres et puis c'est d'une simplicité et
en même temps d'un raffinement ce qu'ils
mangent en nourriture sa renommée
jean-paul la doit à des recettes plutôt
osé à côté de la traditionnelle
margarita qu'il a mis au point deux
recettes inattendues une pizza au caviar
et une autruche
alors c'est à dire une bûche mais à peu
près 2 cuillères à soupe de thé vert du
japon près 70 ans c'est comme un blinis
c'est comme un blinis que l'on met après
que home et de caviar dessus et chaud
voilà comme ça ça donne juste un petit
parfois cette pizza coûte la modique
somme de 90 euros
on sait par l'epita qu'on fait tous les
jours mais je veux dire qu'on autres
mais princier ça c'est la pizza aux
truffes donc on l'a fait cuire avec
crème de truffe et des truffes chaudes à
l'intérieur pour donner encore du parfum
et après on rajoute les truffes fraîches
déçu c'est tout là a bien italie on les
achète à peu près et c'est un produit
phare celle ci coûte 70 euros avec ces
deux rolls de la pizza jean-paul séduit
toutes les clientèles
[Musique]
celle qui vient en bolide jouer au
casino les golfeurs qui profitent des
kilomètres de parcours
où les fans de courses à l'hippodrome de
renommée internationale en plein coeur
de la ville
quarante compétition sont couru ici
chaque année
deauville se réveille au son des sabots
[Musique]
mais avant de pouvoir concourir ces purs
sangs grandissent dans les haras de la
vallée d'auge comme celui de la
colinière ça va bien merci vous bon
alors venez sens oui oui mais magnifique
naissance à ses fleurons chanter les
morceaux magnifiques ou d'antoine à
gauche et propriétaire de chevaux de
course depuis trente ans il a choisi
cette poulinières pour élever ses futurs
champions il découvre sa dernière
merveille
à chaque fois c'est une émotion et il
sait c'est le début du ray puisque
chaque éleveur espère élever une
championne c'est aussi le début des
emmerdements
donc ça c'est souvent là l'activité
solide quand elle aura atteint l'âge de
s'entraîner sa petite pouliche lui
coûtera 16 mille euros par an comme ça
sur jambes
oui pour l'instant tout se passe bien la
première étape est réussie est celle là
en tout cas j'ai je vais la garder mais
je vois je vais essayer d'exploiter en
course jusqu'au bout parce que j'espère
que la mejor a transmis à les fils et
toutes ses qualités
etait-ce exceptionnel dans trois ans sa
pouliche participera à sa première
course c'est du rêve on peut dire que
chaque cheval étant en soi une start up
de dire qu'il faut des choix
stratégiques
il faut un actionnaire ou un
investisseur et comme on dit dans le
pays d'auge est à la fin du bal qu'on
paie les musiciens
l'activité hippique face à l'image de
deauville et contribue à en faire une
marque synonyme d'hôtel bien remplie
quand l'hôtel normandie affiche complet
les serveurs sortent leurs tenues de
soirée
[Musique]
la cérémonie des bougies a lieu tous les
week-ends à 19 heures une tradition qui
marque l'ouverture du bar
sur la carte tous les cocktails du monde
sont proposés mais le chef barman à ses
propres créations
jérôme et solène se laisse tenter
28 mai à côté de la rue
je prends un cocktail est ce que vous
mais recomposer sa chambre normandie
[Musique]
c
traditionnellement rideau ce tout
simplement avec un calvados très très
jeune et on va le terminer tout
simplement avec du canada dry et c'est
une personnalité bien inspiré qui a
soufflé au chef barman le nom de ce
nectar
bonjour comme ça on a eu un client qui
est une fidèle maintenant du temps m'ont
dit qu'ils s'appellent l'on rangera
s'écouter je fais goûter
là c'est beaucoup inspiré il a trouvé ça
très drôle qui est l' image immaculée
morilov maury pour mort et 11 autres au
calme at on dit
c'est le coup de coeur de leur
génération d'acteurs du bar une amende
et c'est une troisième côté nous devons
le plus en ce moment
dernière touche un peu de spray au
calvados
[Musique]
week-end qui commence
cheikh seck vigoureux élégant en 28 ans
marc a dû satisfaire les caprices des
célébrités du monde entier
mais les étoiles ne sont pas forcément
les plus exigeantes
les milliardaires se comporte parfois
comme des enfants gâtés
[Musique]
c'était un puissent venir arabe qui
avait voulu qui arrivait du crayon aussi
bien samedi soir à 18 heures ça c'était
y'a et qui voulait absolument ce qu'on
peut et nioro zay de tlm illisible est
que nous n'avions pas ici donc il
voulait dans une rythme ils voulaient
sur sa table au bar
versailles pour y trouver juste rien
d'hélicoptères opinion ou à briguer une
heure trente plus tard sur sa table
c'est vrai mais ce coup d'oeil c'est
frêche absolument sa bouteille de dom
pérignon rosé mais je m'en souviens très
bien
ça c'est
essayez-vous heureusement accepter mes
week-ends six mois tous les buts ce
serait très compliqué un palace demande
une organisation millimétrée
rien ne peut fonctionner sans un chef
d'orchestre pour s'occuper des clients
une cinquantaine de petites mains
s'affairent dès le matin michel la chef
gouvernante met en ordre ses troupes
tout est affaire de chambre il ya cinq
ans de départ plus lent
les femmes de ménage ont une dizaine de
chambres à faire chacune du linge a
donné un concert historique un palace
c'est une multitude de petits détails et
d'attention comme les fleurs a disposé
dans les suites
j'ai eu la proposition de marie dongou
composition avec lui j'ai remis ni de la
rose de la rose et du lizon tus on sait
vous en pensez quoi
une préférence pour ce vide juste ça
tombe bien parce que c'est un peu ce que
je préfère ça c'est faux pas trop ben
fahd et puis un peu trop compagnie hydro
de feuillages puis ça fait pas classe
enfin on en normandie on n'est pas
convaincu hier c'est aux campagnards et
on n'est pas accompagné aussi il serait
sûrement très jolie ailleurs mais pour
la normandie ça correspond pas du tout
aux chambres et puis même à l'image de
marque du temps mendient l'hôtel s'étend
sur huit mille mètres carrés un
labyrinthe de coursives et de couloir 3
4 km effectivement je fais pas mal de
bordeaux dans une journée très bien
c'est très physique que c'est très bien
ça entretient les formes et la forme en
tant que gouvernante en chef michel est
tenue d'inspecter toutes les suites à
2500 euros la nuit tout doit être
parfait quand j'arrive dans une pièce en
fait j'essaie de me mettre à la place du
client j'utilise dans mon monde aura
donc est-ce que ça sent bon est-ce que
ça sans monnaie ce qui nous donne
particulière après ce que je ressens la
du chaud du froid parce que ma pour le
client c'est important que dans la
chambre il faisait trop froid ni trop
chaud et puis après on ne le fait
d'avoir ce coup d'oeil un peu circulaire
me permet de voir déjà en terme d'
harmonie si la chambre est bien disposé
s'il oubliait bien droit si tout est
bien aligné cette suite est un hommage
au film un homme et une femme
les acteurs jean louis trintignant et
anouk aimée ils sont en bonne place
[Musique]
michel bien je suis allé voir en bas là
j'étais inquiet pour la livraison des
fleurs jérôme limoges le directeur du
normandie depuis deux ans est le garant
de l'image du palace en fait c'est
important que michel soit passé qu'elle
est bien tout vérifier et puis qu'on a
dernier petit coup d'oeil de la
direction qui valide la mise en place à
disposition des fauteuils les fleurs qui
manque rien et que tout soit parfait
pour qu'elle soit loué ce soir ça peut
paraître assez procédurier mais c'est
surtout tu normal parce que cette suite
elle est enfin il faut impérativement
qu'on soit au top
les clients qui louent cette suite
revivre le film réalisé par un amoureux
de deauville
le cinéaste claude lelouch
[Musique]
il partage sa vie entre paris et la
normandie cinquante ans après le
tournage de son film culte la cité
balnéaire lui a rendu un hommage
voilà là la petite place où tout a
commencé en 1966 seriate d'avoir ça de
son vivant
voyez ce que je veux dire en général on
a ça après avoir reçu la lettre de
licenciement
oui oui oui
non surtout que quand j'étais à l'école
j'ai jamais eu le moindre diplôme j'ai
jamais eu la moindre récompense donc
rien pour faire chez mes profs je suis
content d'avoir une place un monopole
c'est sur cette plage qui ont été
tournés les retrouvailles entre jean
louis trintignant et anouk aimée une
séquence qui a fait le tour du monde
devenu une scène de référence qui fait
qu' il ya plein de gens qui viennent à
deauville et qui joue un homme et une
femme
mais c'est vrai que ces planches elles
sont maintenant célèbre et pourtant
elles sont vivantes sont dangereuses
depuis ses planches sont devenu une
légende garantie d'affluence pour la
ville et sa fameuse pizzeria à l'heure
du déjeuner comme d'habitude
jean-paul fait le plein avec ses pizzas
haute couture il a une clientèle
attitrée qui vient depuis plus de 20 ans
comme karl zéro et sa famille
et c'est encore très jeunes qui ont mon
âge grâce aux bonnes pizzas que je mange
ici moi il faut aussi féliciter les
places à bord des films et l'air peut
regarder si ces mecs là qui font tourner
la boutique
et à côté des anglais arrivé le matin
même par avion monsieur le maire avait
vu juste c'est comme à la maison
[Musique]
ce accomplissement de paris
c'est le 21e bien sûr c'est le 21e il
faut que ça reste 21e sinon ce sera le
21 22 23 24 25 26 27 et le jour ils font
tgv seulement onze classes en attendant
la pizza ou caviar et aux truffes a
toujours ses fans
mon jeu
du coup versailles et quelques initiés
et depuis on se remet jamais lassé n'ai
pas beaucoup d'endroits
trouve des pizzas comme ça mais c'est
vraiment et leurs pattes aller
alors comment ça s'est passé vers
d'amour c'est ce qui fait plaisir on
change pas une équipe qui gagne et les
petits jean-paul affiche une belle
réussite avec 600 couverts par jour
c'était bon et va pas bien manger
c'était top
ouais tu reviendras toute cette
clientèle fortunée a eu d'incidence sur
deauville
l'augmentation du coût de la vie les
employés modestes comme pierre alexandre
ont du mal à joindre les deux bouts avec
ses 1400 euros par mois ce jeune homme
de 23 ans n'a pas les moyens de se loger
en ville
[Musique]
grâce aux trois quarts
avec sa copine ils ont dû renoncer à
vivre à deauville où les tarifs de
l'immobilier flirte avec ceux de paris
brins d'osier moyens c'est pas possible
c'est clairement ce n'est pas possible
je pense qu'ici c'est l'endroit le plus
cher au niveau des loyers tout même les
si vous êtes propriétaire tant mieux
mais si vous êtes locataire
à 8000 euros le mètre carré
le centre ville est devenu inabordable
comme beaucoup d'employés du tourisme
pierre-alexandre se retrouve en
concurrence avec sa propre clientèle
les parisiens ont vachement le monopôle
aussi sur la ville on a besoin d'eux ils
le savent ils font marcher la ville tous
les week-ends de l'année voilà et les
vacances voilà on a besoin de ces eaux
qui peuvent l'aider à part comme
celui-là même les htc parisiens font de
deauville un lieu à la mode le week-end
ils envahissent le centre ville
l'après midi ces touristes fortunés font
leurs achats dans le carré d'or où les
plus grandes griffes ont pignon sur rue
[Musique]
là encore pierre alexandre ne peut pas
s'acheter grand chose c'est plus du
lèche-vitrine qu'autre chose celle-ci 1
ap en 2000 et 2500 jetait dans le futur
mais l'a pour l'instant danse et c'est
pas possible on ne peut pas me juger
directement dans le centre-ville
même pour faire les courses et aussi à
l'extérieur dans une zone industrielle
est également mais à fermer
pour l'achat des fringues des vêtements
et tout je pars sur caen 60 km pour
économiser sur l'habillement et pour
diminuer le coût de son loyer il a
déménagé dans un village voisin pour
aider les deauvillais
la ville a construit des logements
sociaux il représente 30% du parc
immobilier
grâce à sa notoriété mondiale deauville
a aujourd'hui encore un coup d' avance
dans la compétition internationale
le maire a décidé d'en profiter suivant
l'exemple de paris il a lancé
l'exploitation commerciale du nom de sa
ville qu'il associe maintenant à des
marques du luxe
oui très bien que ça s'est bien passé
oui très bien vous avez bien alors
en fait je voulais vous montrer ça aussi
parce que c'est sorti depuis une semaine
c'est en vitrine chez longchamp nous
éditons ce sac avec eux c'est la
troisième série ils les sortent par
quelques centaines et au fur et à mesure
que ça c'est puisqu'ils ressortent un
nouveau modèle on parle on porte du
deauville par longchamp par les temps
qui courent
avoir un nom célèbre à l'effet magique
de faire rentrer de l'argent dans les
caisses
un moment où les collectivités locales
reçoivent de moins en moins d'argent de
l'état il nous faut créer des recettes
on essaie de ne pas créer des recettes
fiscales nouvelles et donc il nous faut
des recettes propres
alors ça c'est une façon de pouvoir
gagner un peu d'argent grâce aux
royalties que nous touchons puisque nous
négocions avec les marques le
l'utilisation du nom de deauville ça va
bien alors monsieur le maire tire la
ficelle jusqu'au bout est magnifique
avec sept maris vont lui une styliste de
renom a revisité la célèbre marinière
aux couleurs de la ville
dire ce qu'elle représente alors ces
quatre couleurs rouge vert jaune bleu
dont son dont sont faites les parasols
de la plage de deauville
en général les couleurs sont mêlés sur
les sur les parasols
alors que là vous voyez ça donne une
certaine gaieté
alors ça c'est la couleur du ciel en
permanence à deauville avec le soleil en
permanence à deauville la signature se
paie comptant
agnès b elle coûte 79
la marinière classique voilà 33 euros de
plus
la différence est énorme et pour les
moins audacieux monsieur le maire à un
modèle plus classique
je vais m'acheter
trouvez moi ma taille chanel a créé la
marinière donc retour aux sources pour
deauville en bon showman le maire passe
à la caisse
[Musique]
la marque déposée de ville devrait
rapporter cette année plusieurs dizaines
de milliers d'euros
pendant ce temps là des victimes des
marées cuisson de 5 dans les cuisines du
normandie le chef jean-luc mots tu es
sous pression c'est le dernier test de
la recette vedette de l'été un turbo
sauce hollandaise aux légumes nouveau
clip de sa la bête pèse huit kilos
vous avez souvent des comme jeu
c'est réservé uniquement pour la
normandie pâtissons brocoli mini poireau
pois gourmands pourront pas être sur la
place tout en fraîcheur tout un
printemps mais que nous puissions turbo
voilà ces zones et ils choisissent de
cuisiner ce poisson noble comme une côte
de boeuf dans un beurre clarifié le
turbo va se nourrir de beurre noir dont
bien sûr et ça va je devais encore une
texture très moelleuse là l'intérêt
justement c'est de rester sur une vraie
pièce avec de la vraie matière l'os
dessus il sera servi tels que un turbo
magnifié par des légumes cuits al
anglaise une purée de pommes de terre
passer au tamis et une sauce hollandaise
avec des zestes de citron vert
c'est bien c'est la consistance et sa
place
l'heure du verdict est arrivé
avec l'os
oui
500 modules haut rang sont bien en quoi
son cratère nourri au beurre
à les valider
validez malines est très bons plans
et je crois que ma fille née cet été les
clients paieront 60 euros pour savourer
ce mets droit au même moment dans les
étages aussi c'est l'effervescence à 103
ans le bâtiment vite un lifting
permanent et discret
c'est derrière cette porte que tout se
passe là on va axer dans une partie de
l'hôtel qui est en travaux travaux de
rénovation ont refait 40 chambres de ce
côté là on a refait l'année dernière 70
une remise à neuf
même si jérôme le directeur veille à
conserver ce qui fait le charme des
lieux on ne pourrait pas avoir un hôtel
complètement contemporain avoir des
chambres complètement moderne
contemporain au normandie sans toile de
jouy la toile de jouy est un tissu
imprimé du xviiie siècle qui habille
toutes les chambres de l'hôtel depuis
l'origine
on a jusqu'à 30 chambres qui peuvent
communiquer les unes derrière les autres
on peut imaginer par exemple que celle
ci et la chambre des parents
après on continue on se retrouve dans
une pièce qui peut devenir le salon où
les gens se retrouvent pour l'apéritif
voilà on continue dans une troisième
chambre
on peut imaginer que là ce soit la salle
à manger et du coup on peut dresser
début fait ce que l'on fait
régulièrement des buffet table on peut
me servir jusqu'à 12 14 couverts dans
cette pièce là
grâce à cet agencement un prince arabe a
pu privatiser un modeste appartement de
700 m² coût total des travaux 30
millions d'euros rénovation du toit
comprise une somme énorme mais
nécessaires pour faire face à un nouveau
venu aux dents longues
au milieu de la rivière tout qu il n'y a
que ce petit pont à traverser pour
arriver dans la ville voisine de
trouville
jusqu'à présent les touristes n'y venait
que pour dîner dans lé célèbre brasserie
du port
mais désormais ils pourront aussi dormir
dans le luxe ce nouveau 5 étoiles est
bien décidé à marcher sur les
plates-bandes du normandie après trois
ans de travaux pharaoniques et 40
millions d'euros d'investissement le
challenger est fin prêt son directeur
émile viciana sait que la route de la
réussite est longue tout le monde
souhaiterait avoir la même durée de vie
que le normandie j'ai ouvert l'hôtel il
ya deux jours donc je vais sans doute
pas vous dire que je veux que ça
s'arrête demain
contrairement au normandie cet hôtel n'a
pas d'histoire à vendre alors emile
viciana a mis en place une stratégie
commerciale agressive
il a d'abord recruter un chef de renom
david dranse ancien second du plaza
athénée le palace valin ducasse va
diriger les cuisines sa carte surf sur
la mode des produits locaux le homard
il arrive labellisé du cotentin le mcs
retrouver les bains
tout est dit on a trop film accroître
ville est donc là il arrive des petits
bateaux de petits bateaux qui sont juste
ici la touques les oeufs bio de nos
fermes ballaz on est sur une petite
ferme qui est juste à côté qui nous
fournit tout ce qui est le lait cru
la crème les oeufs il faut compter 55
euros pour le premier menu voir les bons
services
à la différence du normandy les chambres
joue sur un style moderne épuré mais le
vrai plus de l'hôtel se trouve au sous
sol donc ici nous sommes dans notre
institut de thalassothérapie
nous avons trente trois cabines
d'hydrothérapie de massage et il ya même
une piscine souterraine avec deux
bassins
maryvonne oui elle est bonne elle est
belle et bien chaude et je pense que on
pourra l'ouvrir avant quelques jours
ces deux mères évidemment puisque elle
est pompée à quelques centaines de
mètres de la plage de trouville
tout y est il ne manque plus que les
clients la guerre commerciale est
ouverte avec le palaces de deauville
loin de ces tracas j'adore les lumières
normande
j'adore c'était ma qui fait fuir les uns
dessinent en a le sentiment de changer
de pays
vingt fois dans la journée
claude lelouch s'est fait construire
cette incroyable demeure dont il a
lui-même dessiné les plans 500 mètres
carrés tout en rondeur j'ai construit la
maison de mes rêves
la maison où j'aurai envie de vivre pour
un film que je prépare depuis deux ans
qui est aussi une métaphore sur ce que
devraient être les maisons de retraite
le tournage de son 45e film raconte la
suite de l' aventure celle aventure le
long métrage qu'il avait signé en 1972
c'est un décor de fibres et la piscine
est au milieu en plus elle est ronde ce
qui fait qu'on n'a pas besoin de faire
des allers-retours et le soleil rentrer
de partout on est à l'intérieur mais la
piscine est un extérieur toute la maison
tourne autour de la piscine
l'une des chambres donnent directement
sur le salon qui jouxte la salle à
manger elle même ouverte sur une cuisine
à l'américaine
un super loft où chaque chambre à sa
salle de bain et il ya même un sauna
annoncé c'est quand même la maison du
cinéma
l'escalier des stars il y à déjà nar
l'eau voilà et greta garbo voyez c'est
pas des nazes quoi elles ont fait leurs
preuves
elles ont massacré tels que m voilà
alors là il ya rita hayworth
moi je préfère les bronzages les mets
qui ne font pas bander là il ya ava
gardner qu'elle a ce sont des dames qui
font rêver
voilà
m
claude lelouch a pensé à tout pour le
jour et la nuit
[Musique]
on peut déplacer le lit en fonction de
la lumière si on veut regarder la télé
on ne met là bas si on veut bien dormir
on met la tête au nord mais si on veut
suivre le soleil on le déplace donc
c'est un lit qui est constamment à la
bonne place tiens c'est un stade de
plaisir pourtant le réalisateur ne vivra
pas dans ce joyau il a choisi de le
mettre en vente un moyen malin de
financer ses décors de films prix
affichés entre 7 et 10 millions d'euros
cyril maupas l'agent immobilier aurait
déjà trouvé preneur alors quelles sont
les nouvelles avait été bien fait cette
semaine
je pense qu'on va aboutir à mon avis
relativement rapidement dans cette
transaction
en tout cas je l'espère vous leur avez
dit qu' il fallait absolument que je
fixerai utiliser les lieux cocteau
longtemps qu'on l'attend là bien
évidemment stipulé comme il se doit ce
que ça a été conçu pour un film
effectivement donc ça c'est d'ailleurs a
des atouts que nous avons mis en avant
une cacherai pas je suis pas inquiet le
client serait un riche étranger
le maire de deauville philippe augier
est aussi radieux que cette belle
journée
nos splendides planche
on est quand même un week end d'avril
mais regardez le monde
regardez ça les parasols sont ouvertes
en merveilleux il se la joue star
hollywoodienne à nous les acteurs sur
sunset boulevard ils mettent leurs mains
dans le ciment
nous on leur met le nom on donne le nom
de chaque acteur qui est venu à une
cabine à une cabine de bain et il ne
s'arrête jamais alors qu'est-ce la
future mariée allait ou non c'est vous
moi je suis moi je suis le maire du
village
donc je viens vous souhaitez tous les
voeux cette année philippe augier espère
attirer plus de six cent mille visiteurs
[Applaudissements]
les amoureux du monde entier n'ont pas
fini de rejouer encore et encore la
scène mythique d'un homme et une femme
[Musique]